benvenuti a tutto il resto che cos'è
tutto il resto è una serie di video che
nel corso degli anni ho scartato perché
non ha mai trovato posto nel canale ma
sinceramente mi sono rotto le balle di
questa filosofia di pensiero e quindi ho
deciso di farli tutti insieme saranno un
video a settimana per tre mesi ogni
martedì ha già vi sembro a vivere del
fatto che io faccia un viveur settimana
ma è davvero così
ma l'introduzione troppo lunghe fanno
male al cuore quindi partiamo subito con
uno dei miei argomenti preferiti anche
se un po strano da dire vanna marchi
[Musica]
dunque come far capire chi siano
vanna marchi e la figlia stefania nobile
a qualcuno che non le ha mai conosciute
vi ricordate anni fa quando c'erano quei
santoni curatori filippini che potevano
curarti facendoti delle operazioni
chirurgiche a mani nude
in pratica loro ti facevano sdraiare sul
lettino e letteralmente ti infilavano le
mani all'interno del corpo e ti
toglievano tutte le cose maligne che
avevi dentro di te e subito dopo aver
finito il paziente tranquillamente si
alza senza nessun tipo di cicatrice post
operatoria con un po di male interiore
in meno e moltissima gente si faceva
fare queste fantomatiche operazioni
tanto che a un certo punto arriva a
striscia la notizia che dice vegas
guardate che è tutto finto non è vero
che questi fanno delle operazioni
chirurgiche a mani nude
il fatto che qualcuno debba veramente
venirti a dire che quello che stai
guardando non è un vero chirurgo e
quelle non sono delle vere operazioni ma
sono solo dei fanfaroni che vogliono
rubarti i soldi la dice lunga
ma su quelle persone che se ti vogliono
truffare ma con metodi molto meno
esagerati per esempio vanna marchi e la
figlia stefania nobile
l'abbandona nazionale considerata la
miglior venditrice d'italia a partire
dagli anni settanta a loro due si
potevano trovare in quelle televisioni
secondarie che la gente apriva soltanto
per vedere tipo i tarocchi e dopo le
dieci e mezza per riuscire forse a
intravedere lontanamente un capezzolo
femminile cosa è solo da quei canali
potrebbe mai partire la carriera di un
venditore telematico e va la raggiunge
la cresta dell'onda come venditrice
grazie ai suoi modi molto eccentrici e
molto squillanti con cui riusciva ad
acchiappare tutti i clienti possibili
volete togliere alla pancia e beh ma
ovviamente si viene a scoprire che tutto
quello che lei ha venduto soprattutto
negli anni 90 erano per tre quarti delle
truffe ed infatti nuovamente striscia la
notizia torna nel 2001 a dire frat
guarda che tutto quello che sta facendo
vanna e illegale non ai livelli dei
santoni filippini non serve molto meno
per abbindolare le persone
vendeva a caro prezzo dei rimedi contro
il malocchio
ma come faceva lei a capire che casa tua
fosse invasa dal male ti dava un
sacchettino di sale e ti diceva signora
prenda un bicchiere d'acqua e sciolga
questo sale nel bicchiere
ma se il sale non si scioglie tutto vuol
dire che satana cammina nel suo tinello
panico tra le signore di periferia o mio
dio allora prendevano sale lo mettevano
nel bicchiere non si scioglieva e
andavano da lei a comprare rimedi il
problema è che chimicamente non si
poteva sciogliere il sale nell'acqua
perché se continuiamo ad aggiungere del
sale da cucina del cloruro di sodio a
dell'acqua prima si scioglie ma poi non
si scioglie più e rimane in disciolto
sul fondo beh il motivo è che per
sciogliere del sale abbiamo bisogno di
rompere il reticolo cristallino del
cloruro di sodio
qui lo vedete fatto con dei blocchi
rossini blocchi gialli lo ione sodio e
lo ione cloro e per far questo abbiamo
bisogno che delle molecole d'acqua che
notoriamente sono blu arrivino e
stacchino letteralmente gli ioni sodio e
gli ioni cloro
ne servono tante di molecole d'acqua se
aggiungiamo troppo sale semplicemente
non c'è abbastanza acqua per riuscire a
rompere tutto il legame ea tenere in
soluzione separati ioni sodio e gli ioni
cloro e quindi il sale e rimane in
disciolto sul fondo del bicchiere e
grazie a questo processo elementari simo
che purtroppo le signore di borgata non
conoscevano il sale non si sarebbe mai
potuto sciogliere del tutto questa si
chiama truffa e allora striscia la
notizia fa al servizio viene sgamata
vanna marchi e stefania si incazza con
una signora al telefono dove le auguro
tutto il male del mondo
io non ricordo una lezione delle medie
ma quella telefonata maledetta non me la
scorderò magari fanno il processo alle
alla figlia e alla fine vengono
arrestate e potresti qui ore a
raccontarvi altri dettagli tipo che
insieme a loro due c'era questo maestro
di vita chiamato do nascimento che
appena annusato la denuncia lontana di
striscia la notizia è scappato a gambe
levate in brasile dare dei numeri che
vengono così alla casa oppure che vanno
quando era in prigione era nella cella
di fronte ad annamaria franzoni
ma la cosa che mi piace di più di madre
figlia e che non hanno vergogna di
niente se tu dici
oddio mi hanno beccata a truffare magari
mi metto un po di vergogna quando vado a
fare la spesa al conad
no non ho appena sono uscite sono andati
in tutte le televisioni a dire siamo
tornate poi le hanno proposto una
cattedra all'università di bari con un
corso sulla vendita dove tutti si sono
incazzati e ho detto magari non è il
caso poi le hanno proposto di fare
l'isola dei famosi dove anche lì si sono
incazzati tutti hanno detto né magari
non è il caso
ed è qui che finalmente arriviamo al
video corso
io non ho mai voluto veramente parlare
di vanna marchi perché una storia
abbastanza conosciuta ma sfogliando qui
e là qualche articolo sono arrivato a
scoprire che ha fatto un videocorso ed
ovviamente il mio cervello del cazzo ha
detto lo devi avere quindi sono andato
sul sito sul sito della figlia stefania
nobile e mi sono trovato davanti un
capolavoro d'arte moderna il sito oltre
al corso vende anche cosmetici profumi e
magliette per uomo e per donna
un profumo non si spiega dei profumi e
dei cosmetici non sapere neanche cosa
dire delle magliette invece a parte le
grafiche tremende di dio perdona vanno a
novi vorrei far soffermare su due in
particolare quella con la vignetta di
topolino che io tra l'altro ho e non
solo hanno rubato l'immagine di un
fumetto
ipotizzo senza averne i diritti ma chi
lo sa chi lo sa ma hanno anche i sento
dopo digitalmente la parola d'accordo
che un po il marchio di fabbrica di van
e a proposito di d'accordo vorrei
soffermarmi sulla seconda maglietta
rivale la riscrivo però è una maglietta
con scritto d'accordo in tutte le lingue
del mondo ve la siete immaginata
perfetto non ci avete azzeccato è fatta
così di omino è tremenda le scritte sono
tutte a caso non ha una forma non ha una
direzione se lei schede sono buttati
sopra come maggiore delle galline e per
onorare questo splendore
ho creato una cosa che non ho
praticamente mai fatto
ho creato anch'io la mia maglietta la
maglietta che esiste è reale e lo potete
trovare se sembra una presa per il
curvano la trovate in descrizione e il
design l'ho fatto io l'ho disegnata io
ed godetevela certo c'è davvero c'è c'è
in the script c'è e l'ho disegnata io il
videocorso giusto i segreti della
vendita vanna marchi e stefania corso
completo 499 euro invece di 5.250 sembra
retorica ma non lo è affatto e lo so
commento a comparsa o primo attore
dipende solo da te lo sei anche se il
timore di scoprire che non sei tagliato
hicks ti blocca per
per ma fortunatamente sono clementi e si
possono comprare singolarmente o il
primo o il secondo o il terzo episodio
alla modica cifra di 60 euro e deciso di
comprare la terza lezione perché mi
sembrava quella più interessante come
conoscere nuove persone e quindi nuovi
clienti e saper vendere sé stessi e
saper usare le congiunzioni piccola
parentesi ho provato a comprare questo
video corso durante le vacanze di natale
e non me lo lasciava fare perché
probabilmente avevano chiuso le vendite
di tutto il sito in quel periodo è ok ma
perché chiudere anche le vendite di un
videocorso online
presto detto appena finite le vacanze mi
fiondo sul sito a comprarlo e aspetto un
giorno 24 ore dopo mi arriva una mail
semplicemente nominata corso al cui
interno c'è soltanto un link
non un ciao karim non un grazie per aver
comprato il video no un link inviato da
libero mail per ios
cosa dire di queste due ore di video
corso che io ho visto altri master class
non so se voi avete mai comprato delle
elezioni dal sito masterclass quelle
stupende produzioni perfettamente girate
dove ci sono attori comparse intervi non
c'è niente di tutto ciò quel sono vane
stefania che hanno semplicemente
appoggiato il loro portatile sul
tavolino da caffè davanti al divano ed
hanno parlato per due ore e per 60
sberle quanto cazzo mi sarebbe piaciuto
avere almeno l'inquadratura centrata no
è tutto un po scocciato verso destra non
c'è un cambio di inquadratura non c'è un
taglio non ci sono informazioni grafiche
non ci sono immagini di repertorio non
c'è niente e una chiamata di zoom
postuma certo è comunque in sconto da
5.200 euro a 500 quindi non posso
pretendere più di tanto qualche
informazione comunque in questa terza
puntata di questo video corso che arriva
ma è solo informazioni generiche tipo
presta attenzione a chi stai vendendo le
cose stai attento ai dettagli a quello
che dici per adattare il tuo stile a
quelle persone però mentre lo stavo
guardando man mano che passavano i
minuti mi sono reso conto di una cosa
questo video corso e per donne mai meno
ma e calze a rete orrende le calze a
rete
fa strano da dire perché le informazioni
sono universali ma sono rivolti ad un
pubblico prettamente femminile sempre
truccata la donna marie senza trucco ma
età che altissime massimo massimo 78
come vi ho detto prima questa lezione
dura 2ore e tutta la prima ora e solo su
questa cosa qui come vestirsi come
truccarsi l'abito che fa il monaco
un'ora dove spiega sta cazzo di cosa cui
perché perché lei la valigia lei si sa
vestire e ci sono anche gli aneddoti il
tipo quando lei è stata invitata a casa
di dell'utri ha conosciuto berlusconi
che le ha proposto di condurre ok il
prezzo è di noi avevamo pensato a lei
percorre ok il prezzo giusto
pensate se avesse accettato si sarebbe
creata una seconda
timeline nella storia italiana dove
vanna marchi sostituisce iva zanicchi ad
ok il prezzo è giusto piccola curiosità
nello spettacolo di beppe grillo su
netflix grillo conto grillo racconta la
stessa identica cosa e mi offrono questa
trasmissione ok il prezzo è giusto ma
perché io queste informazioni nel
cervello va beh ed è tutto così è un
aneddoto che dura dieci minuti 30 minuti
gli sproloqui dieci minuti di aneddoto
30 minuti sproloqui e siccome devo
vendermi questa maglietta che c'è in
descrizione se ho imparato qualcosa da
questo video corso e che devo andare da
pitta rosso a comprarmi un paio di
scarpe con il tacco minore di 7
centimetri
[Musica]